he grew up hearing how hard it is to get
by on fishing surveys also win doesn't
want to be a fisherman the ambitious 20
year old has a bachelor's degree in
economics be honest at all I want to be
a tour guide tourism could be an
economic motive for this region I can
offer tourists a great experience here
while making some money it's a win-win
situation we win relation ball 5 million
tourists traveled to Myanmar each year
but few of them visit lakin dodgy those
who do mostly come for bird-watching the
environmental NGO fauna and flora
international is working with locals
here to develop the area as an eco
tourism destination Suazo win is one of
10 young local nature guides he's taking
courses in English and ornithology lakin
dodgy is a paradise for birds it's home
to 10 endangered species and is the
winter residence for 20,000 migratory
birds activist frank baum berg says
environmental protection was formerly
state-mandated but now it's the locals
taking action that's not her leash
naturally it's better if they can make
money from bird watching rather than
catching the birds for their daily food
intake as almost still 100 illegal gold
mines around the lake pose a huge hazard
they generate jobs but also spill
sediment and mercury into the lake that
are toxic for its plant and animal life
that's unlikely to change as long as so
many people depend on income from the
gold mines tourism could offer an
alternative
the shwe mitsui pagoda in the middle of
the lake is a must-see for every visitor
here sway comes here every week and an
army airoli I'm grateful that we're
seeing visitor numbers increase here
recently we even had some from Korea oh
yeah and they're staying longer 24 34
days so I have more time to show them
around our lake unlike other attractions
in Myanmar this pagoda isn't thronged by
visitors his way maybe hoping for more
tourists but he is glad he can pray in
peace and quiet